sent something to my girlfriend with
express shipping and it's been three
weeks
two years in the tournament xqcl
[Music]
yes land have a good day i don't
get it any other why rookie three
third world democracy yeah i got more
records in the kgb
so uh no funny business
what
[Music]
two months and i miss yep so much
please felix i beg you bring it back
i miss him so so much how can i threaten
a checkmate if i don't understand the
checkmate okay okay we're doing a game
wow mr cow have you been practicing
xqcl
impressive opener
[__] thirteen months what kind of
research
bang bang bang bang
[Music]
so
trainer cocoona
trainer again and venusaur wait we're in
the game
we're in the game oh [__]
juice liquor i don't know don't know
what to do mike is throbbing
throbbing did we deserve that game i
think we did oh
ah because i think his opening is kind
of bad
listen moist if you're watching
no matter what you do box box i will
destroy you
oh no no no
no it's too soon hikaru
we didn't even reach a climax
[Music]
so
and the dream has been realized my dream
anyway i finally get to host the show
with hikaru nakamura and
um you're choked up
give me the intro i need two chess
legends and yourself danny happy you're
here to join us uh i am impressive in
its own right but
it's no lm or gm
happy to be here yeah agar do you
remember the days when ludwig
didn't think he was the biggest streamer
in chess you remember those days
i do remember those days yes but to be
fair he proved himself in
throughout the event and he backed up
his talk with some great plays so i
think he's very deserving
um of being being the biggest chess
streamer
he's he's he's he's got some records and
he's sporting a new goatee and brought
out his winner best is it cold in there
how's the sweater
look it's i brought my eu sweatshirt uh
it's the it's the smartest piece of
apparel i own it makes me look smarter
i brought the facial hair to the table
why'd you shave hikaru
i just i felt like it's been two months
all right
all right i'll just try to match you i
thought we look good like two gm's of
the game like trying to have
similar facial hair but i'm excited for
the matches today
i have i've watched both these guys for
years now actually
yeah we've got we've got a returning a
returning huge fan favorite obviously an
xqc and then you've got
uh you know someone who's a who's a
movie star the mountain plane later but
all right before we get into that let me
remind the fans just tuning in of what
this is all about
if you've been hiding under a rock for
the last few months then you've missed
it so welcome back to the real world uh
and the pod chance is real
the only real difference in this format
from the event we held in june is that
it is now a double round robin so again
for chess speak
that means we get two games one with
each color it led to some really
exciting moments yesterday we even had
an armageddon
tie breaker that needed to go down
between siz and gripix which was
which was gripping it was awesome to use
my first awkward punt of the day
and uh remember that the whole idea is
that the top two in each bracket will
advance the bottom two will play in a
consolation bracket
and that the prizes have been uh
readjusted just to make sure that
everyone
getting the most the most they can
possible uh
and uh we're gonna be pretty excited as
we get down to the big money games later
on
in the first weekend of september and on
that note here's the schedule
a high level schedule if you will every
day besides tuesdays will be pog champs
days here on chess.com
as we get set for the finals on
september 6th where the three of us will
actually be having the call on that day
so whatever goes down today is i guess a
preview for the finals on the sixth
but ludd in the car i'll let you guys
take the show and talk about talk about
the group
we have coming up here the matches
between xqc and finton
uh wagga and uh the mountain your guys's
thoughts lud we'll start with you
look i've been uh watching xqc today
and yesterday and i've noticed he's been
live for 20 hours
he carl you've entered a few tournaments
in your day is that generally helpful
for your play or hurtful
um that is generally not uh beneficial i
can actually say
many many years ago this tournament in
new york um
called the insanity tournament and it
started at i believe
7 p.m eastern time and it ended at noon
the following day of something like i
think 15 rounds of game 30 so every game
could go one hour
and um from having had that experience i
think the longer you've been awake
uh the less likely it is that you're
going to play good chess
yeah yeah that makes sense i feel like
that's crazy
he did that there's old school stories
love will have to tell you of world
championship matches that required
um let's just say artificial substances
of the non-legal kind
for people to maintain energy famous but
i don't know that xuc needs that because
i don't know he he views his chest
authority but i'm expecting to see him a
little tired today
all right the uh the other matchup oh
never mind let's check in with xqc has
he looks fresh enough right
you're talking about a human you're
saying fresh enough i mean that says it
all right
he he always looks like that i try to
describe xqc to people who don't
watch chess and i'm like he literally
rolls out of bed you can see his
bed and then he streams all day
in the most casual looking pose and he
has more viewers than
everyone else on the internet and i just
don't know how else to describe it
uh yeah yeah that's pretty much him he's
not even human that's that's what it is
well there we got uh clinton who's been
rocking
the best templates ever he had a dj
scene out earlier which was hilarious
and he was
eating and these two guys are are going
to be bringing it let's talk about the
other match up
now this is a i feel like i can't talk
about this one because i coach both of
these guys
i'm i'm a little bit uh i've known waga
he kind of
reached out to us all the way back in
2018 with the world chess championship
and has been a regular
chess guy ever since but but half dory
the guy's just a sweetheart
and he's a crossfit guy so i mean not a
cry he's a much better than crossfit
yeah
i think yeah yeah i think he's not like
the size of my torso
i think that's an unfair picture by the
way all right there's a little
intimidation factor in there i'm just
saying you guys
everyone else is just like a mug shot
and he's lifting a rock
that's threatening in a way yeah he's
like
he's better than i think i anticipated
and his camera angle's gone now when he
streams he improved his camera where you
can see his entire body now when he
streams and it's just
it's freaking crazy like when when i was
coaching him
i just it was intimidating and and he
never and he never stops eating during
our coaching
brain food you know so half dora is uh
it was a fun time i watched one youtube
video on how much he eats it's insane
he can lift more than all of us combined
times two have you ever thought about
that
you can squat a thousand pounds how much
you bench in these daisy karu
all right we gotta upload numbers we
gotta up our number we gotta beat him by
the end of this event i i think i need
to
i think i need to grow by like a foot
and put on probably a few hundred pounds
i i feel like the days of growing for me
are kind of over unfortunately sure
sure yeah i'm growing i'm growing all
the all the wrong ways too
um well we've still got the wrong ways
of growth
is that's the thing you can say yeah it
just
you know just you just roll with it
danny i'm sure
all right well we still got a few more
minutes the guys are ready but we're
ahead of schedule because we were just
so excited to go live so
let's let's get this is your first show
so let's look at all 16 participants
and uh hikar and i didn't even really
have a great chance to do this yesterday
so
of all the new faces you were you were a
competitor in pog one
who who have you been most excited to
see or who are you most excited to see
uh in
this event look i'll give you my two my
two pogs and my two
dogs okay people are gonna make it far
people are gonna sink to the bottom
all right so if for the winners i'm
looking out for half thor
i think he can just send a sneaky dm be
like hey let's draw this and then you
have to say yes
i'm excited about that fourson two i
don't know how he snuck his way back in
but i think i think forsen is just been
secretly grinding off stream
because lord knows he hasn't put any
time into minecraft
and then mizzy wizzy expect
absolutely nothing from him at all hope
he makes it far but that man's
amount of chest on stream has been very
little compared to the amount of
watching pokemon videos
uh and then and then look i i'm just
i just don't know how far cutie will
make it i'm not saying she's dog at the
game i'm just saying i'm not
i don't the highest expectations i i was
wondering if you were gonna call out
your
your non-platonic roommate um is so
what do you think uh well you know i
i've looked over her shoulder on a few
games
and it just she was playing a guy who
was 340
for 340 rated yeah 340 rated and then i
was like oh you got this and then i walk
away and she's like i blundered my queen
like oh well that's that's a low rating
to blunder again so
look hey high hopes low expectations
that's how we play this game
did she say like she was looking for
approval because it's like my kids do
bad things
and but they say it like you expect your
proof like i blended my queen
uh yeah yeah it was more like hey just
like you remember
oh yeah like the old days
all right well um we are about 30
seconds from game time
xqc has been streaming as you said for
too many hours then can be
recommended um as a healthy lifestyle
easy with aces looking dapper in the tie
hey karu your thoughts on what both
players need to do today to be
victorious
um well i think xuc needs to come out of
the opening with a very strong strategy
and get a big advantage
um i think that's his path to victory
for for fenton easy with aces i think
just being stable to start the game
um and just getting into the middle
middle portion the middle phase will
give him
a very big advantage if he can get there
if he avoids problems with the start
he's a poker pro do you think that helps
at all
um i think in general there are some
comparisons between chess players and
poker players there's a fair amount of
crossover
so i certainly would say that i i feel
like um
he he he he because he's a poker player
he's got that um
general instinct for chess in a way that
the people who don't play poker craps
wouldn't have as naturally
i see what game are you sick at if
you're good at chess because i feel like
it's a meme that if you're good at chess
you're five head and good at everything
but like shroud isn't good at every
single shooter because he has great aim
what does chess lend itself to if
anything i mean honestly i would say
it's poker probably more than anything
else
wow all right yeah that makes sense i
was responding nothing because i'm not
good at
anything else um but uh although there
is
oh by the way xqc just won his game we
were following and
that's a good start for him to get ready
that's a good start and uh he was
showing the chat with staff on his
stream
as we've got him uh him pulled up and uh
anyway that is 6 13 ranking we're
writing wasn't his rating higher at the
last event i guess
maybe he gets sniped a lot or something
well the game that's just started
that was okay that was blitz all right
all right all right all right because at
the raptor we see it's 9 24 and it's
actually higher than it was um
it was like maybe 7 7 30 750 i thought
so he's actually improved quite a bit
too
okay well i'm gonna i'm gonna flip the
board here to have white on bottom
and uh we've uh we're we're rocking and
rolling game is on we have d4
so queen spawn we had all e4 yesterday
hecaro or no we have one english but
this is our first d4 i think of the
event
yeah i think it's uh it's gonna be
interesting because i feel like xqc has
a lot less experience against pawn to d4
on move one
and the fact that he's thinking already
on move two is um
is not a good sign i'd say one when
should you start thinking
because i think yeah d4 is i think is
total cheese
yeah so so what i would say is a lot of
newer players for beginners they will
push the pawn in front of the king right
away it's much more natural the
development of bringing the queen and
bringing the bishop out
um whereas playing pawn to d4 move on it
tends to lead to a slower opening
opening phase of the game and so i what
i would say even at this level is they
should know their first like five to six
move
is what i would say and
yeah he's thinking for a while here this
is uh yeah that's that 20 hour he's been
up for 20 hours i feel like
have we not known their studies that
being awake for very long periods of
time is as bad as being drunk
like severely drunk yeah no it's it's
it's worse
it's it's worse than many in many ways
um
is this cheesy he played knight f6 and
finton though again i have three
all three of my students are going down
today so i highlighted the next match as
waga and thor but i also work with
finten and unfortunately he already
forgot one of my first tips which was
that
when you play this opening they need to
protect with a pawn because if not
they've basically given you your goal of
the big center
when they play the move to knight f6 and
i said the main thing you do is you just
take it
unfortunately he forgot he didn't take
it which would have given him his
better chances of a big pawn center and
now he's played knight c3 so
that's sorry the coach in me taking over
my bad sure sure mad at your students i
get it i get it yeah
um now it's turned into a normal opening
like that's the thing
actually it moved the pawn on the second
move we could have had this from the
normal order
yeah um but danny since she did coach
easy with aces i think this is
transposed back into a position that
probably you've shown him yet before
right
yeah so 100 the transposition happens
because as hicaro said
e6 is the move that should get there but
finton missed his small chance and now
we're in a mainline queen's game we went
over this i mean he knows
clinton knows get the pieces out you
know you're all right
you see received any coaching from
hikaru um no i reached out to him
multiple times but
i i think he was kind of busy with uh
among us and fall guys so yeah didn't
have a chance
how does he how is he able to squeeze it
in when he's playing among us for 18
hours
i mean he must he must just really love
chats at the end of the day
is he playing in the fall guys event
with you guys on the 28th or no
he is in that event yeah yeah he's a
captain is he on your team hey carl you
get to be his captain
no no he's a captain as well so like i'm
a captain and he's a captain ludwig i
think is a captain also so
we'll all be rivaled at that event
against each other although
that would be your dream team imagine
hikaru me you xqc
all right we've got our first awkward
move it's not a bad developing move
normally but
oh he's going for cheese he's going for
the cheese danny you got to show the
line on the board so pawn takes
pawn yeah pawn takes pawn knight takes
pawn and you think white's going to win
a queen
but there's bishop what's the move
what's the move here what's the move
right here for
the move right here for black oh my god
okay yeah yeah
so right here in this spot black
obviously going to grab that bishop
bring him on down to b4
wow you're crushing it
whoa yeah that's what i'm saying so then
obviously that spot
uh scary scary scary cheese on its way
vinton did not take it he did not take
the bait i'm not even sure if he saw the
cheese but he just settles on
eliminating the night and
now he could win the pawn um it's got
some risk to it but he could go for it
yeah i mean objectively taking this pawn
to be very good i kind of hope he
doesn't grab this punk because he's he
has not developed any of the pieces next
to his king the bishop the knight and
the rook are on the original squares
yeah um so i kind of hope that he
doesn't grab this pawn after xcc
recaptures with his pawn
but it's it's gonna i think this is
exactly what xqc wants which is
something that
at the start of game is probably not
very good but it's gonna be very very
complicated and there almost certainly
will be some blunders
yeah so so what do you know about xqc
then he likes the tactics that's what
you're
implying there he loves these open
positions where he can bring his pieces
out very quickly and attack
okay um why don't we do our first listen
in of the day we've got him streaming
and
we'll uh we'll all take a back seat and
see what see what insights he's uh he's
given his viewers over there
he's gonna scam me
[Music]
i have to do this first this is so bad
in the event that this happens if i push
this and again he goes away
let's see he goes away he goes away
did you say in the event this is like
the most proper i've ever heard
he doesn't see that the knight is
attacking the queen right now
you know what let's just try it
wait no mike mcqueen's in danger i
didn't look at that okay
wow that could have been game ending
where do i position that lady where do i
position that lady there you go
i think this is fine adapt i get it i
get it
that is the question this is pretty cool
that's not i'll do that i i don't like
that this is all stacked up i think this
is garbage
at least he can't do this to him anymore
we got that we got this out of the way
and i can start moving
doing stuff like this look at that
let's do this going so fast not that it
matters but that's a good movie for
[Music]
music what is happening
do i want that i kind of want that
i don't think he wants that
it's already way down on on time though
he's down more than five minutes already
almost
yes
the pawn can just pass you right stress
out the queen well
then you lose your knight that's
actually why it's a good move okay
nice because the pawn protects the
knight so if he moves the pawn you would
take
and i look at somebody that knows what i
ever when i look at somebody who knows
how to play
their pawns look like art they're so big
when i play my pawns look like
they're missing arms and legs dude like
mr potato
from um the movie dude like toy story or
whatnot
that's actually not untrue though a car
like when you look at a
at a master play their pawns are like
structured there's a shape
right and he's like he's right about
that it does look like art the pawns
where they protect each other they all
make a lot of sense in terms of the
place
what do your pawns look like when you
play lead
you know what i try to just advance all
of them at the same time equally so
they're all next to each other like it's
a small world style
i think that's the safest strat
that's generally that that is generally
a good way to do it because here like
both players with the placement of where
their pawns are on the center part of
the board there's a lot of danger i
think
um for for both sides here because
white's pawns can be attacked easily
black's pawn as well on f5
it's a little bit weak as well are you
stressed about his clock
i've seen a lot of yeah yeah i mean this
is
this is really dangerous he's got to
move faster he just keeps thinking way
too long
he hasn't like thought about an attack
either but this is the best move so yeah
that was a good move
and hicaro made a good point that okay a
big center is nice and you have space
but it's also a
target and that and you got to give
gotta give xqc some credit he's been
attacking it we'll see what he does here
let's uh but he's got it he's got to
move he's just got to move
yeah let's check in with vinton we
haven't we haven't seen what the poker
master is up to yet let's do it we just
want to get ourselves castled
control as much of the center and don't
give up any silly mistakes
when do we go maniac 2000 if we win the
first game and then lose the second one
we kind of left with some egg in our
face but a little mini rave would be
nice
we also have this potentially now but
then this would be hanging so maybe not
we're just going to get customed
i mean the the bow tie is cute say that
yeah he looks like this obviously don't
worry if the teacher forgot
i would like to win with a checkmate but
if he times out maybe
like i said he's been awake for 20 years
possibly he passes out
were you the student who asked for
homework wow he knows he knows about the
sleep deprivation
okay this pollution though is not clear
at all here after black castles the king
this is very very we want to just get
castle before we plan our attack
angle just got castled
i'll just start bringing these pieces
over here okay
um okay look at xqc developing quickly
he's clearly aware of the clock he's
speeding up
okay so how are we going to talk i don't
know i would rather be black
you want to move quickly i'm kind of
tempted to just start running
just looking at fenton's stream and he's
like he's definitely the six consoles
type of streamers these are like polar
opposites
yeah he's got the green screen and the
overlay looks like it's a chess.com
production
right i don't know if that's a good or a
bad thing but i appreciate it
this is six consoles thing danny
um yeah finton is is super slick and
like i said i always try to describe the
biggest streamer on twitch
next he just rolls out of bed there you
go
i mean i'm amazed by what is a what has
occurred by the way because i i'm not i
don't think white is even better anymore
yeah
i agree love it because because like
ludwig for example when you get these
pawns in the center
if they're protecting each other they
make a lot of sense but here the pawns
are not secure at all the pawn on
the dark square is under attack from the
knight and the bishop and the pawn on e4
is also under attack for the pawn f5 so
white could lose the whole center here
very quickly do you see any major
attacking ideas from either side
um i see obvious sort of ideas to attack
the pieces in the center of the board
for xqc for
sure for easy with aces for fenton i
don't actually see any good ideas to
attack her
um he's try i like the idea though
moving the queen out
the bar went down a lot why because
black can move the king over one square
and then the threat is
okay so for example there's a big
mistake here which would be instead of
moving the king over
uh go back one move black and play
knight takes pawn
because after queen takes white is
attacking but for example you're the
queen is under attack from the bishop
on the light square so if black moves
the king over scoots it over one square
first
then the threat of capturing the pawn
with the knight and then attacking the
queen with the bishop on the light
square
is a very strong threat yep
and okay but this probably won't come up
i'm thinking
oh probably not oh he makes the mistake
oh he
oh wow i mean and it's it stinks because
on the one hand
it's actually good tactical recognition
he saw the idea of the queen he
understood he could win the pawn
but it's it's hard it's like the the
next the next level is
yeah see the tactical recognition but
you got to visualize it ahead of time
and now
if easy finds this immediately saw it he
did immediately
drag up the line to a7 oh he did okay
but he didn't see it as like a goated
move it feels like he kind of saw it and
then he's looking at the rest of the
board right now
right so i would say if fenton plays
queen takes pawn he
almost certainly is going to win this
game if he does not take the pawn i
think it's very very likely he's going
to lose this game
well it's funny of course too is it is
almost tricky enough that if xqc sees he
can grab the knight with check
meaning he doesn't he doesn't panic of
this and actually lose the knight
like if he sees this and then frees his
king he's not
he's not i mean it's not over over right
there are some outside chances that the
game goes on here
he has had the queen he took the pawn
right he did it
he had it there for like 20 seconds
before he finally pulled the trigger
but if but if xqc sees knight takes f3
with check and then frees the checkmate
it's not it's not red rover yet i mean
he still has some chances no but it's
very hard with
two two minutes on the clock the time is
going down yeah
i i don't i mean i i think it's very
hard for him to play knight takes night
here because he's going to be so
he's going to be so um so tunneling on
this queenie
checkmate idea here i will say the
pieces that he is looking at are not
a knight yeah let's listen in let's
listen in and see what's going on
songs stressful all of a sudden i know
if i move he just takes that
and i take and then he takes he thought
about all this already
he thought about us already
[Music]
okay if he moves the bishop he has a
chance
uh-oh uh i don't much time
i have a minute not the words again it's
bill 3 it's bill 3.
you can stop the check mate at least and
now but now he only has one move so
he'll see it right away
and now it's game on again
what a weird game yeah yeah because this
has been such a
weird game is it not i think it's a
weird game
well xqc is
[Music]
i think so yeah i call it i love trying
to translate
does that too yeah yeah yeah that's the
sorry moment
is the part tree yeah
yeah okay but he didn't find it he gave
a check that's not the best check so xqc
still has a chance
right and the problem with what he's
doing is that actually that's one move
so it's like
actually i see the move right away
that's the problem with with these moves
is that
the queen block it was the only move the
king move it's the only move
so xuc doesn't have to actually find a
move he gets two free moves
because it's an only option right
now to be fair if i had this position i
think that i would actually i think
black is much better here
don't move the king please don't move
the king if he plays b6 he does
if he plays b6 he does okay
okay this is something i can't think i
don't know this time
so in your mind i think that was really
bad let me tell you
that the strategy might not be so easy
on defense
right so the there's actually one big
problem here if you look at this
position what's going to happen is black
can trade the knights so white's going
to get those two pawns lined up in a row
next to his king but then also he has
this knight that's kind of wandering
that's that's near the black king and
black can actually trap this knight
by attacking with the king the rook or
the bishop
all three all three options would attack
that night and the knight is trapped
he's gonna lose that night
so this is
man very very very very tricky
yeah i feel like finton's been doing all
the work and then after
everything that happens he car still
goes yeah i like black spot here
yeah but i guess he has he executes he's
doing something right
carl pointed out the unluckiness sort of
is like he gave xuc all
only moves like here xqc can't not find
this move like
it you know and then he can't not find
this move so he kind of got himself
in a weird spot look at this move c5 oh
the knight t5 though
better move that you know has multiple
options is what you're saying
yeah because when you only have one
option kind of and it's not even just
one option but
it's good good only options too like
that makes it very
difficult and i think especially at this
level the more opportunities your
opponent has to make a mistake the
better off it is
whereas when they only have one move
they can't make a mistake they have to
find the one move i feel like you're
getting free chess lessons led
look i'm already pat i'm like it's like
i'm uh
you know i'm like shaq i'm on tnt now
you know what i mean like i did my tour
i got my championships i was the biggest
at the time
so this was an old season you know i
maybe i could play ball with these
youngins but
you know i'm just taking my victory tour
yeah
um all right okay xuc does find the
check and so the only problem with
moving the c
pawn is he kind of accidentally gave
finton you know
a saving a saving move but but it's it's
still
it's still tricky the main issue is
clock
yeah oh and that's a really bad move
what
all right what do you want to do let's
go check in with the uh
the kid in school that i didn't cheat
off
but let's go look at him i think we're
just going to not deal with this first
he has a sponsor for emails don't lose
another pond though
that's crazy i don't even understand
that
he found 95 this is yeah
now he's going to win the bishop right
and with that he should win the game
we're going gonna take this yeah that
was an excellent move excellent
excellent fine by finton going knight to
d5 check first saving his knight and now
i can take the bishop next move
and it would take some sort of
catastrophic gonna go out here
i feel like we should have won this a
little bit easier
yeah probably you should safety concerns
me a little bit but i don't see what he
can do right now
but uh xqc gets the white pieces next so
a little different for him from pog one
do you wish you had two games per match
in pog one look do you like that change
no no oh yeah i think it's way better i
think only
for the exact reason that no one can uh
make excuses
no john's as they say because you know
if you if you happen to roll black and
then you lose your one game and you lose
the whole match that kind of sucks
so it just uh gives you the opportunity
i'm sorry
tired deposit you call me lug bud
okay lud i was just seeing a bunch of
lugs in chat
in fact lug is a cool nickname for you
what do you think you're like a lug
that's what my brazilian soccer coach
called me
all right he had a thick accent and i
thought it was his accent and then he
sent me an email and he wrote
two lug and so he just never knew my
name ever
all right let's go see xqc's uh
potential final moments here
kim jiji kim i get my transition
into the loss did you mean did you just
guys i didn't have enough time yo did i
get a b3
built-in right second game i can click
bo2 but
you give him a match too yep
i feel like i'm talking to him i think i
had checkmates
just running a game report don't think
he even i think somewhere in that
checkmates am i crazy
i feel like i don't even know if he had
many checks
yeah he had one chance there was one
chance where he could have been better
but it was very
very hard let's go back to that decor
right here after instead of the move c5
what was your thoughts
or what should black do yeah i think
black shirt traded the knights here
play night knight takes knight pawn
takes and then maybe um
i mean just bring the rook over to the
center of the board maybe rookie eight
is a move
um or something like king b7 again very
advanced stuff though i mean that's not
something
i would get the king out of dodge and
yeah that's enough just so you can open
up the queen lines but again that's very
varied yes i would not expect anybody in
this field to find it
that's a super strong idea because if
somehow if you did that with the battery
like
suddenly it does turn around so i think
he said he thought he had checkmate
because he knew that the potential here
of of the double stacked pawns
i think he saw this but but there was no
uh no real concrete idea
right well he's running a game report i
think both of our players are
are taking an impromptu break he's
analyzing his game and
uh finton has become a fenton stream
he was just there a second ago and look
at this new um by the way i get credit
for that because i taught him what the
what the word zugswang was and what it
meant in our first lesson
and i was trying to describe it's one
thing that makes chess a unique game is
the fact that you have to move there is
no pass
you have to do something and zug's won
his chat loved it there you go
yeah i mean i have to say i've been a
big fan of uh
of easy with ace for quite a while now
fenton's a very charismatic guy very
good poker player as well
i might add he seems like whenever i
watch a stream every other week he uh he
wins like 20 grand so the guys the guy's
a beast and i love the setup he has
um with this uh disco ball even when
he's doing poker and not chest so just
uh
he's he's a lot of fun to watch he's og
too i feel like well compared to a lot
of other streamers
like myself what a cute dog
that's a large animal oh he's winning
the crowd he's winning the crowd of this
dog
you and cutie have a dog yet lud oh we
got a dog yeah yeah
yeah i thought i saw the dog on a stream
one time he's such a whiny [__]
dude
he's one of those dogs that got too
attached to the owner and then every
time he's not here he's like a omega
[__]
and all i want to do is hang out and i
just put my hand out he's like
all right man whatever
all right well finn playing the carol we
worked on this
we worked on the carol so he's um one of
the things about the lessons with him is
like he's been playing chess for so long
i mean he plays chess.com like in the
breaks of his poker streams
he chained the the the camera so i
assumed it was a beer you don't change
with non-alcoholic
all right everybody knows that any
classy european should
wait it's non-alcoholic no i'm saying
you always you can't you shouldn't chin
with non-alcoholic beverages so i'm
assuming it's a beer here
uh but like it's late where he is right
he's uh ironed
like nine or something yeah yeah it's
it's straight it's drinking no actually
he's in malta he's in malta ludwig he's
he's a tax cheat like you are
yeah yeah yeah yeah hey it's just it's
just smart business he car at the end of
the day
offshore accounts um i just enjoy the
state of delaware
right all it's beauty
all right we're in it right this is it
yeah this is uh
he has a chance to do another cheese
with knight e5 here maybe
yeah a little nutty but we'll show it
cheese with nuts
it doesn't work if black knows not to
not to take again
but right something like this should be
fine but that's a hard thing to find i i
don't i don't know if it'll go for the
cheese
probably just castle
i i don't like this opening choice uh
from
from fenton here i think it's perhaps a
little bit easier for white to play if
he knows what to do with like castles
and bring the rook to the center
but also xcc violated one of the basic
principles they put this bishop in front
of this pawn so this dark square bishop
doesn't have a good way to come into the
game that's actually the reason you
generally want to push the pawns
in front of your king and your queen
first that you have squares for your
bishops to go to you have diagonals
but by the way it's an honor to
highlight the ideas that you speak
that's what i'm doing i'm just
highlighting keep it just keep saying
moved i'll keep highlighting
okay now it's your turn now you say
things and i will highlight
yeah this is bad okay
but why right well come on car come on
because like oh my god
pushing out there
what i would say about this is that i
think objectively at like
a grand master level it's probably okay
to play like this but there's a big
danger
when when you're newer to the game of
overextending with your pawns
and you're using your bishops and your
knights too quickly and bring
because it's king again no development
look at this position he's oh
oh oh did he play knight c6 knight tv5
here come here we go
now 85 is nutty oh we got to listen in i
think he sees it he just sat up in his
chair
got him out was that even worth it
dude i kind of want to feel like push
actually i feel like pushing the pawn
now
his thing is annoying me he it's he's
just annoying
i i don't
i hate doing this this makes my thing so
vulnerable i think it's one of the worst
ones ever but maybe i'm completely wrong
what do i know dude i can look at this
it leaves me so vulnerable
is always what's being attacked not what
to attack
mm-hmm get my queen out of there is
there like a switch you have to make or
do you just
like dude i mean i i think i think
you're looking at both john rowley but
the less respect maybe respect is the
wrong word but the less you fear
i always feel weirder when when i'm sick
something wrong i see
once you stop blundering you don't have
to worry about what's
well yeah because i think what he's
saying is he's always worried that that
he's missing something that he's doing
something wrong that's why
he's gonna have some way to win the game
that there's always something wrong you
don't understand how
anxiety-inducing chess is
there was a time when i had these issues
oh yeah you walked uphill both ways
but but i do want to add one thing so
danny if you go back a couple of moves i
didn't want to point this out because
the one thing that i think is very
important that perhaps xcc is having an
issue with
is he's he's not like re sort of
remembering the patterns like
he's played this petrov opening many
many times and the concept is exact same
here
one way you actually probably would
recognize this which is knight takes
pawn yeah
um bishop takes queen and then knight
takes knight and it's a check on the
king and your knight is going to capture
the queen next move
and this is this is exactly what
happened to him in another situation
where it was a queen in front of a queen
on this line and not the rook
um where he lost a very painful game i
mean yeah i've done that against xqc
before and i think he's done it against
me just discovered czech
and just looking for like you know that
time well you tried to you tried to
actually
get him with that trick in your final
game yeah yeah yeah yeah
damn you remember that akara remembers
everything like you said
crazy you were right to call him out on
the uphill both ways hey carl was better
than me when he was eight
so yeah that's why that's why i know he
was lying because he said he could have
divorced his
how he remembers being bad what was the
worst you were at chess you were like
four you don't even remember it's when i
was seven but yeah
tough year dude tough year everyone
before seven seven is the most powerful
magical number
so it can't be tough mm-hmm it can't be
like his naruto moment on the swing set
not even gm
crying the sadness
uh by the way in the game though
actually missed a free pawn i don't know
why
oh he could have taken it oh he had two
chances so he had that chance he also
had a second chance wow
i think he's been operating under what
did i do wrong
this entire set and it's been hurting
him because he doesn't look at it
is that the lack of sleep that he's more
worried about his opponent's threats is
it like the paranoia setting in with
like you know li or is it just that he
hasn't played chess in a while
you know what i would say on that topic
danny and i think ludwig can probably
relate to this a little bit better than
i can um
which is it's just one of those things
like chess is so stressful like
if you're not if you're if you're newer
to the game you're like you just use
you assume that you're not smart or
you're doing something wrong it's just
like it's part of the psychology i think
is that
you just you worry you just you're
worrying non-stop about what what's what
what can go wrong
yeah i think just like it's playing in
pogchamps specifically where you're a
competitor and it's not just your people
watching
and if you lose it's not even that bad
you just get a bunch of lol w's in chat
uh it's it's way more stressful when you
make every move because you don't want
to do something
super dumb and you know you know
a decent amount like i think xcc knows a
decent amount about chess
uh and so it's better to try to show it
off and
not make something super stupid happen
yeah well yes it feels like it's just
like to me i feel like it's like one of
those things where it's like this taking
time bomb you're you're trying like
you just feel like one of these wrong
moves and it's just all gonna blow up
which of course is what makes us so hard
honestly
i think in general most people play
worse like at these events
uh i mean they're worse than they do
when they're just playing on just like
streaming right now you're saying
yeah yeah yeah like the same person they
could be regularly
on stream uh they probably would do
worse on in pog jams
right i think that's probably a thingy
car right like tournament nerves and
like
being able like if you haven't done a
tournament in a while uh you're a little
rusty on tournament play
yeah i would say even at the top levels
there are certain tournaments that are
objectively more important than other
tournaments
and the quality of play for most the
players tends to go down it gets worse
it doesn't get better
so that's definitely true at all levels
we're going to have the question whether
finton remembers on passant or not we
did not go over this in our lesson
you didn't go over all and honestly i'm
watching finton
and he doesn't see it he didn't see it
how do you miss all paso
that was like the biggest thing in the
first blockchain was ambassador
and fianchetto baby
yeah emo for both that was uh
that was a fail right there no one besan
well he gets away with it i mean if you
can get out with that type
yeah i think it's hard to remember
that's not among us that's his among us
practice
all right he's impostor right there he
just went for it he's like i'm i'm
i'm crew member the whole way through
and he got away with it didn't get
called out
nice yup well now it's
now it's back i mean okay black is still
got the big center but if xqc just
develops the knight
then this move c4 was really good
actually and he's this is totally
unclear again
this is another opportunity i would say
as well for xcc to show that he has
learned and he's progressing
because one of his biggest issues has
been the lack of development and bring
using all the pieces that he has on the
board
i still feel like he developed backwards
it might i feel like he put all his like
pawns up and then brought out you know
yeah i mean
it's a little bit dubious but he's
gotten away with it
this is good now he's doing well yeah
sure is quite for sure dubious i thought
it was i like that he didn't
take two like he brought the knight out
behind the pawn so he's got that
and if he puts a brook on c1 or even d1
right now because he's recognizing that
maybe this
it might be a little sneaky verb to see
that the rook on d8 is actually
immediately threatening this pawn here
so he's got to recognize that
right but this game also i like even
though he's down on time he's only down
two minutes so he's
the game is pretty pretty level right um
but i think i think he's doing well so
far now i wonder if he's going to try to
cheat him with f3 here maybe
one thing that uh that bad players like
me don't do is you just look through
pieces
you just pretend they don't exist
sometimes right
right going for the chat f3 would not be
advised for the chat but because
if you don't take it it's bad but but
yeah maybe maybe go for it
yeah i think you should i think you
always go for attacks in these settings
mm-hmm
okay if you play zl maybe now this order
works too this order is good too
yeah f3 i think this game's all about
chump checking all right let them prove
that they know how to deal with it
before you write it off right i feel
like when you're good you just don't
even go for it because obviously it's
not you know
to set yourself up for success that
they're not going to fall for
but here's right yeah so like so so what
i would say yeah
so put that like in the chess terms like
you should always go for tactics i think
like tactics these sequences are a
couple of moves where your opponents
will uh
have the chance to make a mistake rather
than trying to find normal sort of
positional moves that you just improve
pieces
at some point you should try to play for
these tactical sequences of a couple of
moves where your opponent can make a big
mistake really bad players will blunder
and let you win
and then like okay players you have to
let them beat you
by doing tactics against him and then
good players you just lose against
that's my experience
yeah the better the players are the
problem is like the these sort of cheapo
tricks these tactics
they don't really work so you have to
like combine everything and use use
like tactics like then peace placement
it's just yeah it's
it's very hard obviously mm-hmm
just listening sorry go ahead danny
no i was saying i'm just listening to
you guys love it let let's let's check
in with xqc looks like he just went for
a different
kind of uh chump check as ludwig would
say let's see what happens
not like a russian i don't know what
that means but that's out of bounds how
do i feel about this
if he sinks that knight in on eight on
b5 that's what he car was saying i moved
like a4
right what about this like
because he has no puns push like i do
who knows
okay if he plays a4 here he is playing
like a russian
he has
he takes this for free that's
a disaster already no no you guard it
twice
no it is he's not looking to see the
knight retreat because the knights being
attacked sometimes
like at our level we just don't value it
as a piece that can
attack think about because if i stay
here and i'm stubborn and i push this
he takes that and i'm my queen's in
threat
i move her he pushed my dude
and gets that too well that's nah i'm
not no
that's i'm gonna go back
oh oh even if i go back he's not the
same option
the music makes me just on the edge of
my seat of weather i don't know
this anymore the funniest part about
this is he goes back he makes it into
reality
right the one thing he's worried about
i think he's already written that night
not protecting his truth
so he'll never go back to see it
that sounds like i think it's a free
piece i don't even know what i'm doing
okay takes takes okay
he might still do it because he can't
read the line deep enough that he
doesn't know if it's even that bad
and then vincent won't take the pawn
whatever
yes wow it's crazy he did it and said i
i'm going to lose the pawn and
he's not going to wait no it's not
that's not even that complicated
he saw it yeah finally he saw it
afterwards
now will fenton find the winning
variation here as a question
i think this is a good question for you
ludwig
oh gosh okay yeah yeah yeah yeah black
in this spot real quick real quick real
quick if i had to guess
black in this spot has to do something
right flip the board for me flip the
board for me that is not
it was that it that's not it i wouldn't
have done that that's silly right
you could have moved the bishop over
with the pawn supporting it and you hit
the queen and the rook if the queen
moves you lose the rook if you move the
queen you lose
or you yeah give me five more seconds
i'm right there
yeah you call that a skewer
so so ludwig when i said that xcc was
playing like a russian the reason i said
is because right now you see this white
knight
yeah it's guarded by this pawn so it's
this is what's called an outpost there's
no piece that can remove the knight from
the square because it's supported by a
pawn
okay if your bishop your can't attack if
the rook and the queen can't attack it
because
the knight just ha it's completely
guarded it's got that russians just do
that
that's like a thing it's a very
positional concept yeah the outpost
i see so sandy would know he lived in
russia
you lived in russia for a summer that i
would not like to forget
a lot of good things happened in that
summer okay okay
all right go off danny
it's a different show that's a different
show but uh
this is like uh what's that story the uh
talking about some
of the machines um you know what it
could be the first time we're gonna have
an xqc armageddon right here
because i think actually danny ludwig
against xuc was
was armageddon i think well it wasn't
armageddon but it was a it was a single
elimination
yeah blood what color would you take in
armageddon pop quiz
so armageddon armageddon is the one
where
you have to win as white but you get
more time
is that right yes uh i i would take
white
okay i think makes sense yeah i just
think i i
the way i play i just look for mates
even if they're cheesy i just look for
them that's pretty much the only thing i
do and i never worry about defense ever
uh so that's like fantastic advice
you're you're full bill murray space gym
you don't play defense i think i think
people don't look for checkmate enough
in these games
like they're always concerned about
position and things like that and the
basic principles which is
good and dandy but they never once think
themselves like oh how am i going to
even check mate
they just hope they get to an end game
that is their advantage
what's an end game right you know tell
you what it is it's an overrated marvel
movie
that's what it is true true overrated
that ending i mean you can't just do
that
all right by the way if he hadn't traded
the night for the bishop and he had
played this queen check and queen check
idea without trading the knight for the
bishop he would have been much better
maybe even winning
but now it's just a draw but black can
just go back with the king
and it's uh it's gonna be a repetition i
don't
oh you think he goes for that i i'd be
surprised i feel like nobody
has done that in these tournaments and
it's a smart thing to do
but just the idea of going for draws is
not intuitive at all
well i think it's right plus here it's
not really the smart thing i mean he
knows it's a two-game match if he goes
for the draw he actually loses the match
so i think you're right
he has to do something yeah
that's a good move though he's opening
up new lines of shack that would defend
this pawn
i mean you know if queen d1 is played it
doesn't work but you know
what's the added time per move five
seconds yes
and all right
i think we should check in for his final
moments here whether he wins or loses
all right let's do it let's see what
fitton thinks yeah yeah
oh man
i'm gonna be here
i mean if i lose from here i'm quitting
the competition
we'll say i feel like fenton's doing the
thing where your opponent plays fast so
you play fast too
right but he has so much time um
like we can just run and then so if he
checks here and then checks here
take a moment like can he i'm just going
to go here i think
oh no you can't check me the next move
am i being i might be just being
paranoid right now
hey you're being if you're just coming
to attack this like is that what's going
on here we have
loads of time everyone take a deep
breath let's go in the money maker
lounge
real quick there it is where is it let's
go in the money maker lounge
wow quick switching scene that's just
everyone has to take a couple of deep
breaths you ready
you ready
oh my gosh i want this
chris moneymaker that's not let's not
let's not let him check make me down
here if you're not going to twitch.tv
so much isn't giving him like this and
this game over but i just don't know
that was epic and then i go here he
checks here
i take like i don't i don't see it but
i'm a bit paranoid and danny always
tells me i'm running away from ghosts
that don't exist
i i do tell you just take this and
that's your turn throughout all this
all right all right that's just okay he
just gave a draw it's fine
that ghost was it doesn't matter he
still wins he has 12 seconds on the
clock
okay so that's actually going to win
oh queen e3 is a nice move we played
we're going to lose this pawn but it
just doesn't matter
we're gonna go here we're gonna promote
we're all gonna have a good day
ten nine eight seven six
five i don't think that's how seconds
work but he is ahead
oh man
uh oh two queens are better than one
wait no it's oh oh oops check me
okay let's go let's go all right
tree blunders again don't think we
covered ourselves in glory but hey
we got the job done we can open up
discord i didn't have anything open
that was a great great entertaining look
excuse he was talking about forcing a
draw in his stream at the end there but
i don't know if he knows
that it's not actually best of three
it's best of two
which means a loss in a draw is still a
loss right
right exactly it is confusing because
there's like a tie breaker so it feels
like a best of three
yeah but if you're up 1.5 it's still uh
i guess the
the act of drawing is unique to chess
all right well uh the the act of drawing
didn't occur but we do have another
match coming up they've both gone live
they're streaming
don't go anywhere we've got more ludwig
more hikaru and more pog champs when we
come back
excuse me was talking about forcing a
draw in his stream at the end there but
i don't know if he
knows that it's not actually best of the
three
sorry i was muted jet i was muted
all right we're gonna stop watching the
uh stream there
what a good game though fun to watch
so my game is not scheduled until 15
minutes from now so
i don't think it starts early i don't
know though
if they want to start early i'm here
though up to them
take a message
and they can message yeah soon
so say your last words chat
beautiful beautiful
well i'm ready to play i'm excited
it'll be fun man
i'm assuming daniel invites me to game
or something i'm not sure
norway versus sweden norway you mean
iceland sir
yeah communicating moves in chat will
get better get you banned so don't do
anything like that
don't do anything like that but uh you
know i hope you enjoyed this i hope you
have fun chats
i'm definitely gonna have fun myself so
it'll be uh it'll be entertaining
yeah all right emote only
for you guys now good night chat good
night
thank you so much
and then afterwards afterwards we'll
have you guys able to speak again
there you go glorious
that's not it ten minutes unrated
wait is that the no that's not his
account though
yeah i'm not gonna squeeze in one final
game before
sorry sorry usa
sure you can communicate through uh
communicate through uh commands mr
bistimon
but no talking oh my god vips can talk
we're gonna have to on vip mr please
team up for this
then one time he gets some power
there we go we've on vip two v
and uh there we go
very good both 2v and uh
mr beastymon no talking for you
no vips
oh my god it's me i'm up
dude i want to play oh i want to play
chat
i want to play man 2v support anti-major
any daughter people in chat
good stuff i i've been invited to
uh match against mountain yet i don't
see it
nothing yet
unless he's playing on a different
account but none of these are his
accounts
but i'm ready
and we're back here joined by by both of
our players
xqc and easy with aces guys uh thank you
for joining us first of all
and what's going on um
sorry what you're we're we're talking to
you right now this is live we're live
excuse me we're live
this is the game we can't hear you so it
doesn't matter
did he not hear us no
can you hear us now he looks great
let us know if you can hear us man some
of that guys i can't hear you guys it'll
take a second
yeah actually we had this issue with
hafu yesterday too so
bottom line yes carrot
and then uh what is it so
for confusing 24 hours or something
let's give him a little break
oh i got it boom yo
yo what's up what's up yo what up what
up
thanks man uh live troubleshooting but
uh
hey well speaking of doing things live
you you played super well the last
couple games have you been playing games
when you're not streaming on chess.com
how much have you been practicing over
the last
month no i'm not the point of myself
i've been um
i wasn't i'm not gonna lie to you guys
i'm
a hard worker but i'm committed but um
there it's been that open a short short
comings with that with chess i
i could have done way more um are you
at your prep today because you stayed up
for 21 hours before playing
hey yeah i know i know you're from
youtube but
you think you know stuff like i did
streaming i'm a stream warlord okay yeah
i i i don't need to prep for my stream
and
and about going to sleep before playing
a tournament game
you took one minute on your second move
game one
i thought you fell asleep at that point
i'm not gonna lie i was just worried
about look they say sleep exhaustion
it's we're just wondering about your
yeah your exhaust i mean are you tired
or are you feeling good
i think then that's okay listen can i i
don't want i don't want to create drama
listen
this way this guy up top is like a chess
caster gm over there
probably i am over there what the heck
is
ludwig doing you're casting it you're
like 900
i beat your ass oh
in a tie breaker like three minute match
if you want to look at the biggest chess
stream of all time it's not hikaru it's
not you
it's me all right that's why they bring
out the big guy all right the big guns
i'm glad that i'm getting interviewed by
my my co-worker ludwig thanks so much
i did not pray that much i couldn't wait
more i could have been better um
but it wasn't fun though so
good go ahead yeah no i'm just going to
ask um in general how did you feel
throughout these games because even if
you haven't been um
spending a lot of time on chess it seems
like you have improved relative to when
you last played so
did you feel like you were playing
better today than like in the previous
pog champs or do you think that
experience maybe helped you as well
i feel like i had an idea of where my
pieces were going
and had like a flow of things of like my
pieces are moving
i'm moving forward without making big
mistakes but i feel like
he was thinking a bit more ahead and
he's like yeah if he does this that this
well i'm gonna do that i've made lots of
mistakes dude i made lots of mistakes
i've already
think yeah we listened in on both you i
think xcc gave uh
fenton a lot of credit uh and there's
certain times you could have like push
an advantage
just like listening to guys like fenton
we'd listen in on him and he would just
he was always like anxious and nervous
and you both were at points but
i was sitting back having a beer i
thought i was nice at one point he moved
his queen up you went
through the game and you were freaking
out about that you had to
move to your couch cam that's my
opponent
yeah yeah what's going on mate yeah
awesome man
wait what people said it was like a
poker play i thought it was like gonna
be like
like some like 20 year old doing like a
hat which flames on it
sure sure yeah you did outdo us all
in the uh in the commentator attire yeah
and the extra streams uh the extra
scenes you had we had the money maker
room and the disco room fenton you came
you busted out all the stops here today
i was a little bit paranoid when i first
changed the room that it could be
looking like
that i was changing it for you know to
like i don't know cheat or something so
like i quickly changed back and panicked
and i was like
you know it wasn't my move when i was
doing it and stuff so i thought you were
seeing i
yeah that's what i see that you know it
you coach me you tell me i see problems
that aren't there
i i i don't have any chess questions for
you guys honestly it was a lot of fun
um your guys your guys's games were fun
and xqc i mean i know
like you said you were uh maybe maybe
you didn't think you put as much time in
as
you should have but i i agree with you
karo it felt like you you played
you played better than the first event
and i was wondering if the experience
paid off are you feeling at least more
relaxed like you're not nervous
about your matches when you play well i
feel pretty good like i
i was happy with like um i i didn't feel
like i he got me like oh no the fork i
didn't think about
oh no the back the back rank he got me i
i didn't feel gotten and i feel like if
i if i
if i had crafted my skill i spent like
more time these small details would have
would have mattered like knowing how to
develop how to push my pawns like
knowing what i'm looking for
these are the patterns that are they're
going to come up that i will use later
on or something
uh and singles flare up you know like
two weeks
coaching session can we expect a coach
coaching session with uxqc
yeah i'll be back with a nickel but i
got lazy
it's been it's been an experience uh
check your dms it's so sad
cars just reaching out every day like
hey excuse me i think i i think
ludwig is offering okay what's up
i think ludwig was offering to coach is
that what you were doing
no no no no well i look at my profile
my writing goes like up and down like i
want my rating to go up
not not okay
look i'm just a commentator this time
i've already done my tour uh
you know i'll take on a few students
maybe in the future i'm a commentator
there what can can i have one last thing
though
that's really just for xcc specifically
which is that i don't know if you can
bring up the board danny very quickly
but from that second game there was just
one i already know which one you're
talking about is that there are certain
patterns that repeat themselves like you
see it in one game and it happens in
another so like in this game
i i don't know if you can see the board
right now and zoom but there was this
one position
if you're just holding it yeah yeah you
could have played this knight takes pawn
move
and after black captures the queen here
with the bishop
you can take the knight and you're
attacking the king with your rook so
it's a challenge they can't go get it
again
yeah you get to get his queen on the
next move
that's sweaty and this is a pattern that
you had in a couple of other games
as well so it's just something like when
you see this mistake like
just try and remember this idea with
this with like these checks and
and these discovered attacks for yeah
it's like a
pseudo sacrifice right exactly
i was a little i was a little
disappointed when you missed that buddy
but i'm
hey no i'm i'm just kidding overall
seriously you played great
yeah sometimes it's a piece i'm like
that's a threat that's a threat that's a
threat
and i i never compute it as like i it
could be a tool to get something out of
it you know
right i felt like you were always well
the way you're talking is always
defensive and you're
like and a lot of the times you were
good and everything was square but you
thought you had done something wrong and
you could have just attacked more
yeah i kind of felt like i haven't been
in that pattern like uh like enough
times
to be comfortable with it that's all
right but i i would say in general terms
that is true is like you you
i think this applies even to like fenton
for example where you always assume
there's something wrong you
assume you're missing something because
you're new to the game or you're your
opponent
they set some traffic you don't see but
for the vast majority of the time
you're doing completely fine so i think
confidence is a big big role in just
trying to be
aggressive and attacking especially for
ux you see makes makes more sense
because you're very good at that it's
more
of an instinct thing and you have those
instincts to attack your opponent's
pieces
yep all right guys well thanks for
having me on and
inviting me thank you both for joining
us we got we got a match coming up now
between the mountain and wagga but you
guys were awesome and uh we'll we'll
probably catch up with you after your
next match
all right guys
all right after julius taking on waga
uh yeah you guys think i could take him
though right like if we did like like
you think i could take him like
xqc like if he did a match probably be
like you know i think was
such a long breath hikaru i just needed
a yes all right even if it's a lie
no i mean i i think i think objectively
you're right that you would win the
match i think what it comes down to for
xqc
is that it's sort of the the ability
like this the way he would study it's
like
playing is useful up to a point like
getting some of the patterns down
but there are certain spots where it's
more than just playing the game like
doing these puzzles like trying to
understand what these
ideas are and understanding these
concepts and i think if xcc spent more
time on that
he he would be significantly better but
because he doesn't do that and he's only
playing the games
there's something that is just like it's
not really learning whereas i actually
would say with you ludwig
um like when you played that final game
against him
in the first pog champs it was very
clear you looked at his games or you had
seen that
that specific pattern in this petrov
opening um so you'd done that like
specific like
targeted look at what his games and his
patterns and the strategy whereas i
don't think he does that and i think
that can also play
a big role in terms of the study
approach not working as well for him
it's all readily available and i feel
like people don't look at it because i
you know i think that's a lot of what
helped charlie too
is that he looked at it not only by
himself but with donya
he would just look at the openings and
then figure out what to do i just
happened to look at it the
the like in our break when i played xqc
is that i i i had a plan and it didn't
work and i was like i'll do it again let
me just
try to play better well honestly ludwig
that's that's very five head because
i think you're probably the only player
i i mean in this event who would do that
so the fact he pulled it up and looked
in between like in between the games
like that's that's pretty
pretty brilliant worked out it worked
out
just following our next players um
we'll be ready to rock as soon as the
game start everybody but yeah and uh
anyway couldn't agree more and i think
he i think he liked the advice i think
he knows that to be true but he's just
often he's grabbing a chess game in
between stuff where he just doesn't take
the time to like
learn from the game it's more i think
it's just content right because it's
like it's more boring to analyze a match
than to be
in a match and it's also more boring to
do a longer match would pro which would
probably be like better to play in the
same environment you're going to play in
the tournament right as opposed to like
a three-minute blitz
which is like you know it's just like
you're not even thinking you're just
like
making moves um which
can help like to play fast but it's not
gonna help when you do your ten five
right exactly yeah yeah i mean i mean i
think again it's
for x you see he plays so many games
with so many of these different things
that it's
it's it's tricky um but what i will say
is that i did
i do remember watching him play chess
during that brief boom and i think 2018
like november
and when he played forsen he was just
like losing without even being a game
and i think he played force and now he
would still probably lose but it would
not be where it's just like there's no
understanding or just getting blown off
the board and like
being down a queen on on the tenth move
it's an actual game not like uh like a
one by the way it looks like
right mountain didn't realize meaning uh
half door didn't oh the mountains
playing the hillbilly gambit we got the
hillbilly the hillbill
walk me through the line he's playing
that because he plays an italian hikaru
but yeah go ahead
sorry wait what's he normally plays the
italian
and so that's why he did that he's not
actually trying to play the hillbilly
i promise okay okay anyway yeah so it
this is the same opening of ludwig it's
alaskan the carol khan black pushes two
pawns in the center
um and xc played knight f3d5 so he goes
bishop c4d5 and treats the bishop
and um and so this is a gambit because
now black can take the pawn for free on
e4
okay and so it was actually just the
italian but he got scared and backed off
and then it looked like the hillbilly
well this is a real but then it ended up
being the hillbilly anyways yes you see
yeah
hillbilly attack because you've gambited
one pawn why is it hillbilly
okay fair enough i feel like some sick
dude from kentucky who changed the game
that we don't know about i i don't know
either
um sure fair enough um
history of chess is a long in storied
affair
long and storied usually named after you
know great cities and random italian and
french guys but
one guy snuck in there hillbilly yeah
and
uh there you go not a gianco piano um
is there still stuff by the way you can
make like by the time you're done
chassis car
can you get a heat can you sneak one in
there can you sneaky no
there might be some like some minor
variation you could consider
something like that but no there will be
no major changes i think they might name
the bong cloud after you
at some point it's all branding so all
you have to do is just play it every
single time and they'll call the hikaru
right as long as you keep winning yeah
right but i won't win after the first
time that's the only problem
okay yeah that is a problem uh all right
well okay we've got
we've got some games actually rolling
along now and looks like hofstra has got
his stream going let's listen into the
mountain for the first time today and
check in with my boy my student
absolutely crazy holy [__]
oh okay it didn't start well
uh but it's going well now he's taking
the center
uh i'm just gonna castle i'm just gonna
castle here
um i like that i like that
i like castling yeah
bringing my pieces to the center uh
staying calm he does this in our lesson
he does this in our lessons too
[Laughter]
he seems very calm like he's gonna like
break something after that
thumbs up very calm half thor very calm
that's what i was going to say is he's
very good at giving insight into exactly
what he's feeling he does this in our in
the la
where he just says got to be calm got to
be patient
got to take a breath got to see the
whole picture these are the things he
says out loud a lot
yeah maybe he'll bring in like the uh
like the eddie hall technique and just
get his mental state into like the
darkest point to whip out his
secret chess skill
what
never seen him with hair before yeah
he's legend he's let it
that looks good that's that quarantine
cut
similar beard to myself
both uh both nordic mean him
where is he specifically from uh iceland
iceland oh he found a great move by the
way bishop g5 is a fantastic move as
well
let's uh let's talk about wine
that we're both like nordic and my blood
did this to me and his blood did that to
him
like that's that's weird right we came
from the same
land yeah let's just say let's just say
you did not win the genetic lottery
yeah something happened like which one
of my grandfathers [__] up
i don't get it why did this happen to me
guys
hey dude i was born with a receding
hairline so i'm right there with you man
you have it yeah yeah i
uh guess do we think about the board
here hikar what are we both thinking
here because i'm thinking
very complicated yeah like the
i think what uh i would expect wag mama
to play is probably oh he goes back that
way because the
white can remove the knight with the
bishop and then capture this pawn
on d5 potentially because right now
black guards it with the knight so if
you can get rid of that knight and then
you can
capture this pawn so it's very
complicated hard to judge
now it their ratings seem high do you
think half thor is
better than xqc is that straight up oh
definitely
wow okay yeah yeah i mean because ooh
wait no knight p5 was played or not yeah
it was it was oh
okay that that's that's a strange move
um but yeah what i was going to say so
with half thor
um i think it was it's probably a month
and a half ago i gave him a lesson i was
very surprised because
i i assumed he was very new to the game
but he clearly has studied at least a
little bit and even if he doesn't know
like the names of the terms and the
concepts in english um
he definitely has a background with
playing chess and he even mentioned this
that
um when he wasn't when he wasn't lifting
like during some of these breaks he
would he would play chess against some
of the other
other lifters who he was friends with
yeah i was watching
you guys were in a position and i think
you had advantage and then he said let's
draw and you said okay
[Laughter]
right he's drawn against the gm before
that's impressive
well he's a hard guy but otherwise hard
guy to say no to
yeah well he brings the knight right
back which is
actually probably the best movie could
do after knight to b5 he just comes
right back and
now we'll we'll see if he recognizes
this uh oh
he didn't still very unclear though very
very very hard position to judge one
thing that i will say that's odd about
this game unlike a lot of the other
games that we've seen so far is the
position
where the pawns are um to use the xqc
phrase it looks a lot like art the pawns
are all kind of similar
there aren't many open lines and pieces
are going to be coming off the board
very quickly so it's it's a very
dry position let's check in with wagon
we haven't done that yet talk a little
about nicholas he uh
he became a big fan of chess in 2018 he
covered the world he followed the world
championship and for those who don't
know he's actually been
the commentator for the official dota
world chess championship
um i think a couple times so anyway
let's check in with nick let's see how
he's doing
what a great looking background behind
him it's it's wallpaper by the way i
confirmed
i don't have too many squares to move it
and it's just like it's attacking mine
it can look pretty my knight and also
attacking yeah
attacking the um the d-pawn
so it's under attack by both the the
queen
the bishop and the queen the bishop and
the knight which is kind of scary
because i'm only covering it twice
i think i'll take out this bishop
let's think for a little bit tiny what's
fine to you sometime
yeah we are stretching it
seems a okay to me
yeah very balanced position though even
though black's up to one pawn his pawns
are overextended in the middle of the
board so it's very uh
yeah very very hard to play he has an
attacking idea here still
because you can take my um
[Music]
take my knight out
his rating seems like one of the highs
in the tournament so he can still do the
attack um i think i think he might be
the highest seed i don't know danny
danny could confirm that
we're just going to castle he's probably
the highest rank
now he might win this one back to groups
for scheduling on monday
he takes here nicholas has
literally been streaming chess for
several hours every day
this week and so he's he's that he's
gained
150 points just this week he's got a
full box box
yeah all right fair enough and he said
he was going it was funny because we had
i had trouble getting to hold him i knew
he
i knew he was going to play a huge chess
guy but when he accepted the invite he
didn't get
back to us for a few weeks and then he
was like no i'm going to stream every
day
and he did and now he now he's really
improved just over the last few days
so yeah so
i mean position is very again very
balanced here black is one extra pawn
but everything is weak in the center
yeah if if if hoftor sees this i mean he
can
okay he i don't think he realizes i mean
clearly wagga did he pointed out a lot
of times he knew that he had pressure
but
afterwards not seeing currently the idea
of getting this getting this d5 pump
back
or he's just smarter than you danny and
he wants to trade and then capture the
pawn on d5
followed by capturing the pawn and e4
that's also possible
there are a lot of people on the show
smarter than me
what i'm shocked you missed that danny
the idea of this is true because what a
car is saying is if you go for this at
the end of the line you actually lose
the b2 pawn anyway so this is not
bad icaru fine okay
um but uh but okay we'll we'll see but
the biggest thing here is look how much
time blog has taken actually he's
already under four minutes
yeah yeah actually this is true i think
it's just overthinking tournament nerve
stuff
i think you know it doesn't matter if
you play eight hours a day it's
different when you play in the
tournament uh and
the one game matters
but i think software just can't decide
where he wants his webcam and he keeps
changing the position
yeah the producer is constantly having
to change the camera angle
he's working hard over there he just
slammed his head on the table
because because software decided to move
his camera again
yeah this is uh
you know one thing i would add having
given half her a lesson is he's very
very good but he tends to move too
slowly so the fact that he's not
he's not behind on the clock is very
promising for him because usually when
i've seen him play he thinks too much
and he has too little time yeah
um so right now he's up like two and a
half minutes because of that hicaro
in our last lesson that he and i did i
think was on monday i pushed him to oh i
pushed him to play some blitz in case he
reaches a tiebreaker because because he
is a slower player but uh oh
that move walks into this if wanda sees
it
yeah well i mean if he's he's playing
four or five hours every day he probably
should see
it whether he will see it i don't know
i feel like the whenever you play a game
against someone it's very cyclical like
if they play slower you play slower and
then if they play faster you play faster
there's like a there's like a rhythm
that forms and it's hard to pull out of
unless you have a scene you can switch
to with pictures of chris moneymaker
all right
sees it ah yeah this is gonna be tough
do what he thinks
a little concerned about that face i use
the ass of you
you could have a really good commercial
for a ford truck if you just put them in
like a toyota corolla
yeah yeah this doesn't work out
he's what six seven right i think
do that or six nine i have to wiki it
yeah either way yeah
either way it is crazy you can just
google how tall he is huh
six nine yeah oh my god
i can't believe there's a taller chess
player than me
got an idea though
okay found bishop h6 i like the idea at
least yeah
yeah we have confirmation he's six nine
crazy crazy coffee man in the chess tv
chat confirmed six nine
wait is he 452 pounds no
probably yeah
i mean the googled way i'm sure it
fluctuates
when you're eating that much like day to
day
i just don't know that it fluctuates by
that much uh
205 kilograms 69 420
right exactly
he's six foot nine 420 pounds all right
six nine 420.
in 2019 he was 379 when he won the
world's strongest man
yeah wow that's what i'm saying you got
it to the chest tv's
yeah so i mean right now yeah guacamole
is doing very well i think this knight
move is very pesky
um i feel like probably wagon mama the
fact that he's seeing these tactics
shows that he has
played a lot in the past this knight h5
move is very very annoying to try and
hit the white queen
and that's not the move that i would
expect most uh
most um newer players to play i would
expect them to like move a bishop back
or something
yeah uh he's playing well
here we go confirmation 69 420 nice
okay we'll see if waga finds this move
f5 that would be a little nutty
oh that's really nasty well what
on to f5 it's a torque the right it's
the same problem that he had the first
time right
right except here it's even it's even
worse it's a queen and a rook
yeah there's also knight back which also
forks the queen and the rook as well
yeah what do you call that because i
that comes up a lot in chess it's
probably the most
i feel like common tactic that comes up
it's a fork
or just for just straight up fork okay
yeah fork is when you attack two pieces
with one piece
and when you move one you're gonna lose
the other one i think specifically the
pawn one i feel like comes up a lot and
might be the harder one to see
as opposed to like everybody sees the
night one no one misses right
right right well and the pawn one is one
that literally kind of gave it its name
you can visualize the fork right
uh i see the fork in the road yeah so
a knight two i mean if the knights here
and you've got this kind of you can see
oops apparently i can't draw but that's
a fork like more like a trident
yeah that's some asu stuff
all right uh well one thing that
one thing hofstra is going for him is
the clock though now look at this move
rookie five yeah the clock oh my gosh
one minute
and this is a good move he's threatening
to take the knight
apparently not a lot i feel like they
both haven't said a word in the past
five months
you're an emotive player uh hikaru
yeah yeah i feel like when you play do
you talk to yourself
um sometimes i do you usually not i mean
there's difference because over the
board chests when you're in person like
the irl you can't talk during the games
like online certainly you can because
there's no one else around
um so sometimes i do but generally
generally i mean i'm just the thoughts
are going i think i'm [__] up but not
really you do the stream thing where you
like look down and you look up and then
you like use your fingers
and then you like count 70 well i do i
do that regardless and danny could
probably actually talk to us as well so
like it's just a general like it's just
a general like recall thing
it wouldn't even matter if it's chess
but i think it's just something with
like the pattern recall
that like a lot of people do right dan a
lot of players do it it's actually a
i've joked about it a lot but it's
actually a uh
it's the same reason people look away
when they lie because you're
you're accessing a part of your brain
which stores like memories and
imagination
and so like top players takara is not
the only one like often when they're
calculating something that's not present
to their eyes you're actually accessing
like memory
and it's something that you do naturally
so like you're
yeah it's a it's a real brain science
thing so yeah
so so you're doing this when you play uh
play uh among us right
uh yeah yet
uh tom's getting really scared i look at
hofdor hoffrord knows
his only chance is the clock i don't
think there's any immediate way he can
lose from checkmate either right i mean
yeah
no no oh that was a good move though oh
that was a good move bishop a3
oh no he tried oh no he's going to lose
now why
he had so much time i feel like i don't
understand why he made those moves but
isn't it what you said before about like
this this
cycle where it's like when you're go
when the other guy's moving fast you
move fast when they're moving so you
move slower
you're feeling the rhythm it's like a
mirror easy game that could have been
for half i mean i guess you don't want
to give your opponent time to think on
your move but he had
five minutes and he took four seconds to
make two blunders
right right yeah i think that was that
that's also why i like i i've stressed
before with players and pogchamps like
you don't want to play a lot of these
blitz games
because it's not natural like making
these moves instantly you're much more
likely to make a mistake when you don't
don't think at all
yeah i will say the one beef i think i
have
with pogchamps format 105 specifically
is that there's no immediate game on the
chess website that lends itself to it
cause there's 10 0 which you get no
extra time and then there's 15
10 which is way longer uh outside of
that that's true
yeah that's uh it's pretty fair feedback
right there
yeah because tenno's technically blitz
right right
it's like the longest blitz we could go
1510 it would just be that would people
still play i guess slightly longer games
but
uh yeah i mean i i'm not sure what the
solution is it's just interesting that
that's the the present problem we might
have to add it the pog control
i mean obviously you can play it but
it's not what you're saying is it's not
a quick button
yeah it's not a quick button there might
not be people in queue as well right
because people are more likely to cue
the ones that are automatically set for
them
right yeah true and so might be
is nintendo even popular or more popular
than like ten five like i feel like
nintendo is much more popular
well is that just because the site
offers it or is it just like chess
it is partly because it's the default
suggestion for new players
so it is the most popular but it's also
very popular amongst established players
um
the most popular time control amongst uh
like 2 000 and up ratings is 3-0
added time is less popular is that it
yeah yes
but danny you should just add that to
the queue you should make 10-5 just a
normal control yeah we can
that's yeah good feedback by the way
wagga cleaned that up there and that was
i i think you made a good point
obviously
just that he was playing too fast but
the difference between someone like
hikaru who could use a time advantage
versus others like you don't have to
give up the rook on b2 like
if you make problems and keep the game
going you might have actually had a
chance you only had 17 seconds right so
as soon as you start playing only moves
you also make it obvious for your
opponent what the best move is to
respond
right and then that then that adds back
to their time now they're gaining time
right so
anyway that could have been a closer
finish than it was for sure
he had such a large advantage that any
move he did even if it's a blunder would
have been fine
because it just adds time to his clock
and he's ahead by so many pieces
right all right well
lucky for thor we've got another game
here right he still has a chance to tie
this thing
give us give us a tie breaker but uh
he played well i think he beat my ass in
game and out
yeah yeah i mean
to be clear but i think he'd take me
so i think he's reflecting a little bit
let's let's see how he's feeling
things go bloated appreciate champ uh
that was the first game guys
rough game i lost it i absolutely
[__] this one up
i got nothing
positive thinking absolutely i agree
guys let's let's let's be positive
awesome hey positive hop door stay
positive
is wearing a strong man shirt like
hicaro wearing a chess player shirt
a strong man
you imagine your car just wears a shirt
that says chess player because it's not
even that he's the strongest man he's
like he's saying
strong man chess player like labels
let's label people
what would be your label lud uh
uh streamer streamer
or or biggest chess player of all time
all right okay here we go we've got d4
in a london
so this is the levy touch hicaro i
warned you of this
levy was throwing the uh the london
system
to a lot of his students right
he's been teaching london he's also been
teaching yeah he's been teaching
everyone d4 i hate it
he's ruining the game right
geez e4 is the truth
yeah i know i've had this philosophy for
a while and tell me if i'm dumb
but on black especially when they play
like this
can't you just copy everything white
does to like move eight
like he's doing now not exactly because
what white should do is push the pawn
from c2 to c4 um so if white push that
pawn black can't really copy because
you're going to
end up in a situation where you're
behind by one move for your development
sure right but if they don't if white
doesn't if white isn't aggressive then
yes you can just basically copy
play cop the moment they're right
i see alan's still playing fast though
that's good i mean if he
he could he could continue to copy at
this point he could also very now maybe
offer the ch oh very nice he does plays
bishop d6 i like it
i feel like this is the one of the most
common positions i feel like i see
when yeah especially for the d4 or kind
of london players right
yeah it's it's i mean pretty pretty
standard so far
i like that he takes with the queen
doesn't take with the pawn
but yeah very very slow game this is
gonna i would say what
for wagamom though i think he just
should not use way too much time here
because
it's gonna be hard to um hard to think
of
a lot of ideas here so i would just play
quickly and play naturally with white
because you don't want to end up way
down on the clock again
is there an incredibly resident sleeper
opening that you know it's just going to
be a slog of a game
um i mean probably the the london
this london system is one of them uh
what else he's calling levy a boring
player maybe
maybe an exchange french yes
but but to be fair the thing is levy
doesn't actually play these openings so
he's teaching them these openings but he
doesn't play it with white he doesn't
play the london system
well part of the part of the appeal led
to the london and why levy does it is
because
now this is not totally true but i'll
just over oversimplify say pretty much
white's moves are the same
almost every time right so what he's
doing is he's simplifying
kind of the learning curve so that they
don't focus on it they can focus on the
type of middle games that it brings or
focus on the type of tactics that it
brings which is
it's not a bad like poaching up he's
just kind of saying like
he's eliminating the need for
complicated nuances and just giving them
a position they can play pretty much no
matter what black does
i do not totally true but that's the
idea that was box boxes
strategy i remember was like just to
have an opening that he can do every
single time
never think about the first six to eight
moves and then he can play chess
right uh whereas some people get hung up
on you know four minutes in their
opening
because they just don't know what to do
and they're trying to remember it's very
equal game though i mean this is
deadlocked so
yeah it's pretty pretty balanced so far
okay i don't know if i like that move
but i think he wants to be active
whereas wagon
was trying to play something very slow
very quiet where not much is happening
very resonant sleeper kind of
um and half what i think is getting
frustrated by it a little bit
i think this is the next system is that
kind of like the french
and this yeah in a sense i mean it's
just you play it very very slow very
very quietly
and you wait for your opponent to like
get a little bit frustrated i think and
i think half the we're playing this
night move is he's a little bit too
quick because there is no threat of a
checkmate the knight guards this pawn
on on h2
this is kind of the next level in
hofdor's chest remember he played the
knight v5 move in the first game he
he does this we've talked about like
once he kind of gets out of the opening
stage and he doesn't have a plan
this is kind of like his this kind of
go-to he does the knights to the edge he
also goes for like a knight and bishop
going for f7 a lot i think that
that'll be the next thing when we go
over lessons is like giving him
different plans that aren't just
kind of superficial threats like you
know get your pieces out and build
strength like learn how to gain space in
the position which is
i talked about space being strength if
you can gain space with your furthest
advanced pawns you have more options for
your pieces
that's the next thing we're going to
work on i think one advantage is that
it's
although maybe a superficial threat
taking two minutes of time up
that's true because there are big
mistakes you can make
in response and so wagamama doesn't want
to make them uh and so he's thinking
maybe a little too hard
but now there is a trick maybe black can
bring the knight out
you see it already danny i'm sure like
knight c6 white tries to play a move
like pawn to h3
who removes the knight from the square
and black play knight takes pawn
boom boom and that's
that would be a little bit you know next
level for hofdor to see but if he just
develops naturally he could kind of fall
into it and
and of course waga could play a move
like this which might be his idea to
sort of block the diagonal but
a nice c6 is a good move it's a tricky
move yeah i like it
oh but you're pretty good at this chess
commentary thing
you know look i i just see the moves i
let hikaru say him that's kind of our
thing
you know right like sometimes and then i
get to highlight him
yeah you highlight i dm me car what to
say you highlight what he says
i like the kid i'm the kid with the
coloring book in the classroom
you're the kid who knows the answers who
rolls up with the pouch with 70 pencils
and you have to say yes but we won't be
your friend
right my bad i'll never return them
all right yeah also a good move close
yeah it's
it's probably a better move i think i
think the thing here is that white has
these pawns
uh these pawns on d3 and d4 these two
pawns in a row and
they are a little bit vulnerable in the
long term because they can't go forward
they're just stuck there
yeah yeah anything that attacks it's so
funny hikaru though if you played knight
c6 there's your h3 move that would have
been funny right
he was one move away please don't get
forked here that's all i'm asking
so ludwig do you see what happens if
black moves the knight back to this uh
dark square
okay good yeah that's actually right so
so so danny make the other move yeah
yeah you're gonna get a pawn fork
on e5 yes exactly because the pawn
behind it supports the pawn and then the
queen and the knight are forked and
you're gonna lose one of one of them i
think that's the one thing i look to
avoid because it does happen
like it happens a lot when you play is
uh just never have them like
i don't know if they call them two away
from each other opposition
right after playing well though and
again still up a couple minutes on the
clock let's go let's listen into waga
see what he's handling i want to keep
that tension my boy
daniel he was talking about tension a
lot during our coaching session
he remembers the talking about the
tension this kind of tension
or uh sexual
hmm let's get some
rooks involved or get the queen i was
thinking about this and he could
take that's not so good for my pawn
structure again though let's just get on
c file i think
how do i get my second knight going as
well can you do something
can you activate we're kind of blocking
you and then you're blocked here and
you're blocked here
you really can't do anything so that's
one benefit of moving my queen is
my my uh knight could come out
this way i really don't want him there
though i want him here
this knight could go there should he go
there now i can tell why he takes a
while to make his moves
i mean he's really overthinking this so
i would say yeah
that's just it yeah this can't be that
bad
he's definitely the guy who like on a
math test in high school i have to do
ten plus
this guy's [__] sure on a calculator
it's unfortunate but this guy
this guy could peppa hop in he never
forgets to carry the one i'll tell you
that the issue is
he could take and then i
take with a pawn but suddenly he can
move his queen out
you know and also yeah
he doesn't like my pawn there i'm sorry
but we're gonna have a pawn there
not gonna move just yet sir rash talk
i'm sorry we're gonna have a pawn there
he's getting out of there his prison
break
he's gotta get involved with his rook if
i go that way
now i could push this pawn
i can tell he does comment i like the
idea of cutting off his queen's diagonal
yeah dude
yeah yeah the way he talks he also
weakened his king a little bit there
with that move what if it slows him down
to be honest and his
pawn push can't do anything yeah
i think going here that's the only
reason i don't like the idea when i
stream
i have something better good at
commentary
i'm such a good streamer
it's such a shame now the thing about
taking
it is then i give you know again freedom
to the
tonight on on this square he just comes
in and takes so i don't like that at all
or the rook you know maybe he finds yeah
wow
finds the move right kick him yep yeah
playing well and now it's hard for him
to do everything it's such a good move
this is now black and smooth the queen
and then the pawn falls
falls on the dark square the queen can
no longer guard and white will capture
with the rook on the next move
in fact hofstra doesn't even really have
any good choices with the queen i mean
trading is
really not great [__] back to e7
feels bad
yeah this is pretty hard to play yeah
he's he's deep in thought right now
well it shows you a little bit of the
difference between them i think waga we
talk we did talk about the pawn tension
like once you got this like just build
on it and bring
pieces to these squares we had a few
examples of that and the difference i
think just
difference in chess level i mean thor
kind of did that for a while but
eventually sort of broke
instead of you know bringing more pieces
into the game and that's
kind of the big difference right now so
there you go feel a huge time advantage
yep
yeah i mean i think i think at this
point um
he goes back which is a good move i
think it's a better move because you you
need to keep more peace on the board if
you're going to be behind here
yeah yeah
but i will say the thing with wagon mama
though is is the explanation
like he's using these terms that like
you would not really expect
expect players to be using so it's very
clear that he studied quite a bit he has
a very good understanding like pinning
the knight and the queen
like you know he's he's got all he's got
it all all
going
what's so he did use the term prison
break what's that one usually what's
that
that's that was a no i mean wasn't that
just a pawn break
uh yeah was it was for the pawn move he
called this a prison break which is
yeah that's from a different experience
he's had
okay sure sure all right that's a
different experience he doesn't like
that
he doesn't like to talk about that
anymore um
yeah but uh no but you're right nicara
despite despite the prison break term he
is using a lot of high level chest stuff
but he's one of those guys who got into
chess from watching over-the-board chess
right so he comes from like uh
like he was a fan of watching watching
high level chess so i'm not
not surprised and i wouldn't be
surprised to see him as one of the
favorites yeah i mean to win it all like
we said his rating just keeps going up
right
dominating the file budwig's old job
dominating the file now you now look at
you you're retired you're commentating
on the file instead of dom i'm
washed man i'm washed i'm gonna make my
car come back all right i'm gonna i
don't know what it'll be for me i'm
gonna find
i'm gonna find streaming or something
like he did a big comeback
wait you say i'm washing chestnut are
you saying no no no no
no no no you were washed now you're
better than that
baby okay
all right
ricardo drove across the country and
then played magnus in a final
it was uh yeah yeah i i drove across the
country because like i i really want to
i want to play mini golf against ludwig
that's that's the real reason i drove
across
i would roast you mini golf you don't
understand man
all right every every day i wait i get
better because you're old bones
you have to hunch over i'm going to give
you the shortest one the way you know
like the ones they have for kids they're
going to run out of the big boy ones
okay you got to hunt away
yeah but i can do that anyway you just
you just hold it like really at the top
and you hunch
and you just bend right over and push
what is this technique
no you know you stand with the bernhard
langer or whatever it is a german guy
he's like he puts it he holds it at the
very top and just like
turns all the way down yeah all right
look i'll set up i'll set up a mini golf
course and we'll we'll duel
for your gm title
and i'll put up uh i'll give you my
uh stream key that's all i have of value
that's all i have
card all right that's all i have
oh man uh how does black get out of this
situation
what does he do if waga trades
everything and takes e6 it's over
yeah because the queen is going to be
removed from guarding this pawn
and um oh man yikes
uh oh
oh man this is just bad news
it's already two pawns so the other
thing is white has what we call past
pawns so you see the pawns
next to each other in the center on d4
and e5 on two dark stories they have a
free passage all the way up the board
there are no pawns in the way so they
can go all the way to the end of the
board
um so this is yeah this is really really
bad for half thor
speaking of players practicing though i
just have to point out because i'm still
following him from yesterday's streaming
car
david pakman has been playing blitz for
the last two hours
i'm just showing his game real quick
he's like this guy is practicing a ton
we'll go back but
shout out to pac-man who hasn't stopped
playing blitz for all day
yeah i mean i i think one thing that i
would say is it feels like
uh the players who are the stronger
players they're
they're very very serious about it and
they're taking it very seriously which
which is good um so you see pac-man you
see it's hofu
um or you feel like even like gripex for
example like they're really really
serious about it so it's gonna be a lot
of fun to see what happens
and i think unfortunately like mizzy
wizzy um
is in for a very very rude awakening
yeah enough yeah i just think the two
things everyone could do
is look at the opponent's opening
because you can just literally
chest search their username and find all
their games
which is a crazy feature it's cool uh
and then
also i think doing puzzles and tactics
is what a lot of people do
but i think uh what charlie did was just
do one tactic
so he would be able to see it in game
because it's one thing to just
do a tactic and kind of see it if you
have like four minutes
uh and it's another to recognize it when
it happens in game
if you just do [__] 600 forks like he
did
you'll see every fork in game yeah yeah
that that's a very good point right that
no it's true i but i would say also
though
it's not i think some people it's easier
to spot the patterns to see it
like some people see it but then like
you know like with x you see this
pattern that he had today
has occurred i mean at least probably
ten times if not yeah
but like maybe it's just he's not
looking for it but he's not able to put
the
puzzle pieces together in that same way
whereas like charlie i think when he
just did it over and over again it just
sort of got internalized in his in his
his brain
i think it's like a big thing of the uh
the bobby fischer book the bobby fischer
like play chess book he does like
400 back rank puzzles they're all back
ranked puzzles but
or at the least at the start and then
you just right we'll never miss a back
rank after that
right exactly yeah yeah it's true well
there's just no substitute for the i
mean
sounds cliche the hard work charlie's
just literally putting in a ton of
time right just memorizing patterns it's
just the truth because
i think right before an event you know
you could argue you want to do more like
the puzzle rush style do things that
challenge your time management and just
a bunch of different puzzles where you
don't
you don't have the the bird on your
shoulder telling you it's a back rank
because then then you're challenging
your
you know your awareness and your and
your critical thinking but
i think if you're going to put in the
time then you should use that feature
where you can be like i'm only going to
solve
double attacks all day that's the theme
today double attacks right
or or back rank but you know if you're
not like i
told i told mountain like we were
chatting on discord he was like how
should i get ready should i do a bunch
of
like one theme i was like actually try
to do some other things that are a
little more
like puzzle rush style so your your
clock management is better but obviously
my advice went a long way
yeah i like how you say i told mountain
yeah i told him what to do i told you
mountain
that's right mountain
uh he was super disappointed we had our
first lesson i said like hey man big fan
and he was like thinking it's from the
hbo and i was like i've never seen game
of thrones i'm one of the two people
left i'm one of the guys
there we go here comes the chat he goes
to carl's disapproval i've never seen
game of thrones
that's that's a disappointment that is
yeah you've been living under a rock
have you seen it of course i have yeah
yeah
he cares you know everyone has and he
sat down and read devorsky's endgame
manual so it's not like he has
leisure time well you know ludwig to be
fair
danny actually literally studied from
the guy himself when he spent
his uh
do you ever bring me up like do you ever
do you're like don't mispronounce oh
we have we have a potential crazy mate
oh yeah yeah oh
it ended the legendary uh what is it
suffocate
it's called smother but yeah exactly
yeah
oh let's check out thor stream the full
man
unfortunately holy [__]
sorry man you just bench after every
single loss
as a statement
yeah i i think he was just over match he
was just out matching this this this
this this um i mean admittedly his
hardest
match-up in his in his group by far so i
think
he did pretty well game one he was up on
time the whole time so
you can still make winners bracket
pretty easily i feel like
yeah i i think i think for sure i i
think it's just yes
when you play the also when you play a
strongest player and you lose though i
think i think it's better that way
because like you know you play the
strongest guy like for example say
you're you're playing the other people
first you know you have to win
because you get that final match if it
goes wrong it's just like
i mean you just know you have no chance
make sense agree totally that'll be his
challenging advice because he already
had the toughest game so all right we'll
be right back to talk to both the
players so don't go anywhere interviews
coming up with the mountain and wagga
mama
in just a couple minutes
[Music]
and we're here with the uh the strongest
man in the world the mountain
there it is off door it was uh
these were these were good games today
these were good games today and
like uh like okara was just telling you
it seems very clear that waga is one of
the tournament favorites so
i'm glad you seem to be feeling pretty
confident right about your chances still
well yeah i'm to be honest with you i'm
a little bit disappointed in myself
um but what can i say he was a tough
opponent
he deserves the wins he played
absolutely fantastic
i did my best i came short you know
he's the better man today i just have to
keep grinding
um get some more tips from uh my
my best friend higaro i think he's
hiding something from him
you haven't even watched game of thrones
how can you be his favorite
i am i am his coach uh he said he's his
best friend best friend
best friend your best friend is
different do you have his friends
different yeah yeah i just like like
like i i like to by the way in that best
friend i like to
you know make like my like
hikaru he's the best you know and i like
to make him my best friend so i can be
as good as him you know that's that's my
end goal
maybe you're looking for someone
slightly like a larger chess streamer if
that's the case then i can also
squeeze in there would love to teach you
a thing or two
he's better than you are man well look i
can't
at least point out something uh game one
game one you had a huge time advantage
almost could have won it and then had a
couple you just
were playing so fast with five minutes
yeah do you feel like you could have had
that game
i felt like i had that game in the back
yeah
i think when i make the mistake when i
was when i took my queen away uh that
was
i think my blunder i should have i sort
of kept the pressure
because he was i feel like he was uh
probably freaking out because he was
under time a lot of pressure going on
there
yeah i sort of just kept the pressure
kept my focus
but i don't know what happened to me i i
i i
i backed down uh and and i lost the game
you back down you started making moves
like uh every second with five minutes
on the clock is that because he was
moving fast too you felt the need to go
fast
or because he didn't want him to think
on your clock
honestly i think for the future games
i'm gonna i'm gonna use my time
um yeah i think i think if you're in
that spot you go hands up
hands up and you just don't even touch
anything for at least a second just to
make sure that
like hey he has 11 seconds this is
pretty much in the bag just don't throw
uh or give him anything easy not even
throw just give him something easy
yeah yeah yeah uh but still good games
what do you think about can i ask
the meme because every time you're in a
game twitch chat
likes to bring up the fact that they
should draw to you immediately
forfeit king round one or else is there
any truth to these rumors
these memes that's actually hilarious
that's actually hilarious i mean i mean
if if if my opponent won't want to like
if
they if they want to like i'm not gonna
like you know
you're not gonna tell them to no i'm not
gonna tell them to because like of
course not but like if they
if if they feel like they they they need
you know need some break or they they
forgot them
eat instead of eating instead of you
know playing against me that's that's
fine that's fine you know like yeah
i'll take the win you know i'll take the
winners away afterwards you're supposed
to you're supposed to go like this and
say if they want to
if they want to they can nothing like
that yeah buddy
um well i we're going to go over your
games i know i'm not your best friend
but i'm your coach
and we're going to go over your games
and we're going to learn from this and
you're going to come back stronger than
ever
absolutely i'm willing i'm i'm down
you know i'm here to learn guys chess is
new to me
and i'm here to learn like like bring it
bring it i'm ready
yeah i think uh i think honestly your
favorite to make a winner's bracket
which is impressive in its own right so
i think i think that should be the goal
for sure
and then see how far you can take it i
appreciate that man thank you so much
i i would also add just one last thing
as well as it's
i think it's really good when you play
against the strongest player who's in
your group at the start
because then there's room to improve
whereas if you play the other players
first it feels like
in the last match it's going the other
way where you're playing somewhere where
you'll lose
there's the chances to improve and keep
studying and getting better as the event
goes on also
are good so it's tough day but yeah it's
going to get better
absolutely there's a saying that says
it's better to start bad and finish
strong then
then then start good and and and bad
what about if you're constantly starting
bad and ending bad like me well
that's absolutely that then you
basically just [__] okay okay well
that helps i appreciate that
all right man seriously great catching
up with you more more chess lessons
coming and
enjoy the rest of your weekend and don't
worry i'll send you wagga mama's address
absolutely absolutely yep
appreciate it bye-bye yep and that was
the man
the strongest man in the world and like
yokoro said it was a tough day for him
but that was our day overall
uh 2-0 for both easy with aces and waga
um but for for hof tour we'll see it's
kind of only up from here as far as the
strength of his opponents
and i think finton though also impressed
today you know
we'll see if he uh he continues to build
on that too but all right
bring up the full schedule here remind
everybody although today's day is coming
to an end tomorrow
mizzy busy makes his debut
um we've got uh cutie making her debut
and ludwig will be back for commentary
on that one
um i don't even know what's gonna happen
tomorrow i won't be here tomorrow
ludwig will be holding i think me and
ricardo get a break tomorrow
yeah i'll be holding it down uh you know
when cutie plays maybe i take a couple
bathroom breaks
walk in real quick are you doing
commentary tomorrow maybe i'm wrong
i thought i was but then you probably
are i don't even know the schedule my
bad
that's me we're [__] up right now this
is funny
i might be able to add some little w's
but if i'm able to
do some commentary without you car
that's a we're in trouble
it would be so funny if you were doing
the commentary so i mean
you and xqc would have a great time
going throwing down
two co-workers just letting the people
know
uh but yeah good day of chess i'm
excited for tomorrow i hope miz
impresses that's what i'm looking
forward to
all right well uh on behalf of everybody
here
thank you so much for the viewers tuning
in don't go anywhere we're going to be
raiding the man hikaru who's about to
kick off his own channel
um i know ludwig's going to be in the
chat that's where he spends most his
time watching hikaru nakamura streams
right i miss the valorant gameplay i'll
say it okay
where'd it go bring it back i'm tired of
watching you
choke and fall guys right back rant
okay i'll i'll try in the coming days
that sounds good
hey carl's going to be streaming so
we'll be rating thank you again to
everybody who tuned in on behalf of the
crew
the chefs.com staff the mods everybody
ludwig esquire the third
and hikaru nakamura i will say make sure
you tune in tomorrow for more pog champs
and we will see you then
[Music]
so
you